today on our show Jordan Peele is making
something new get out I saw something
new puns like that today on fat man on
Batman Batman Kevin I am NOT bernardi's
uh let's dive into it shall we yes
Jordan Peele
Jordan Peele Zemke and Peele half of key
and Peele nobody says that anymore now
they just say get out drew and out join
what they don't they get out Jordan
Peele they say come in Jordan Peele and
pictures your ideas indeed after making
a 5 million dollars was a budget forget
out and glasses a plumb house movie Blum
has really 110 million dollars worldwide
they made us I made a buck or two you
know there's a real world in which get
out I think might get a Screenplay
nomination Wow it's a long time member a
long time but like that movie had enough
heat had enough of a sort of pop
cultural footprint and I think there's a
way you can bring that back regardless
nobody could be hotter in Hollywood
right now than Jordan Peele I believe
they gave him an award at one of those
you know [ __ ] the show West right way
through talent of tomorrow our share of
the year or something like that would
not surprise me because get out was
really [ __ ] strong well I saw what I
saw JJ Abrams when I went to see Jeff
Garlin had a premiere for his Netflix
movie handsome hmm at the ArcLight
and Jake Abrams is there as well and I
was chitchat with him and he goes uh you
know you know Jordan Peele and I said no
who is that he goes get out and I was
like oh you mean Keane people oh yeah I
mean I don't know him but I mean I know
his working stuff and he goes we're
going in to pitch he goes you gotta meet
him is good guy because we're going in
to pitch tomorrow this great idea is
going it's a show that's kind of like
all the 50s har and sci-fi movies and
tropes but now done from the black
perspective and I was like oh my god I
guarantee that gets picked up quick and
that's kind of that was my hot day cause
I bet you something created by the
guy who's like hotter than hell right
now being produced by the other guy
who's been hotter now forever until the
end of time I wonder if someone will see
the value in that show they did I knew I
was right I knew I was catskin HBO has
picked up Lovecraft County sounds a
great idea for a straight to series
order nothing between 8 and 10 episodes
as these things tend to be right yeah
1950 set anthology that kind of tackles
race and horror and the south which are
a great [ __ ] idea there's so much so
much meat in that particular oh my god
like I just think about a completely
different perspective for all of it
different story then you'll ever see
that you had before the familiar tropes
that you grew up with and now made more
entertaining by somebody else's saying
like I cannot wait for his
body-snatchers episode I cannot wait for
the blob episode I cannot wait for the
[ __ ] giant hungry ants episode is
this a show that would you take it
staffs does it have a writers room or is
he write them all um apparently he's not
running the show someone else is a guy
named Misha green I think he's running
the show he will be executive producing
I'm sure he will be in the room because
he has a very specific and in particular
view on horror and how it affects
socially because I say this for every
show but it just so happens that this is
also a black show hired this guy hired
this guy oh my God he's like one of the
greatest writers ever
I always think he should be writing for
everything but this smells like you
would you would blast us out of the park
I my first heard about it I was like I
wonder if marks barking alas I'm not I'm
working at a different venture but you
know when that's over call a brother
Jordan you know oh my god it's a good
idea I can't wait now do we know
anything more about than that we know so
very little it's very simple what a
newsman hard-hitting news we know so
very little back to you
Lovecraft County rough country love it
love it now we'll go to win it because
we know some of them both but here's the
weather future looks bright because that
sounds like a [ __ ] cool thing HBO
don't what they always do you know
nice on town to be in Netflix before
Netflix does Netflix that's what HBO is
very good huh first and 10
yeah well Arliss Silas dream on
[ __ ] you Netflix we were dreaming on and
mandy's well it took them a few yeah
well you know get to the wire on the
first shot very true alright so that's
good [ __ ] new abandons bang what else
you got we got [ __ ] from the DC Universe
is happening David Gore's Krypton show
for solid is a sci-fi pick up to sci-fi
pickups David Gloria's Krypton 50
Network ladies and gentlemen
sippy sippy your future is philosophy
and what it was as a Krypton Krypton
clip trying to fit two generations
before the destruction of the legendary
Man of Steel's home planet I said this
joke before and I'll say it again hey
kids you know the most exciting thing
about Superman is his grandpa he never
talked about and also can't fly have no
superpowers but that's okay look you
know we're sitting here blowing Jordan
Peele because they're like oh my god
he's gonna have new takes on old stories
maybe maybe that's what Krypton is maybe
it's a prequel that you've been dreaming
of didn't they try something like this
with the Belser Galactica I mean Vicki
Africa New Caprica or whatever just grab
Prakash Caprica you know what if it
sound promising like oh [ __ ] this is
about how the Cylons come to be and then
then it's like what if the dam is dead
was like a lawyer okay cool maybe he'll
do some defending of an in establishing
AI president in the Caprican court
system not going to tie in the Supergirl
at all unlikely [ __ ] yes [ __ ] Supergirl
was tremendous this week soon we're
coming in for a strong landing good
friend and I know there's this next
episode coming up I've been hearing
about this storyline
since the beginning of the season and it
makes me very emotional can we be Paul
it's good stuff good stuff and flash is
wrapping up to you know as we're
recording somebody might have died
something big happened tonight that I
also knew about Angie Christ for kids
you know and when he told me guess what
kids that's right I cry we
Beauty weeks that's all I know it's good
dude that's the gold standard keV steers
the gold standard to tears balling
that's what [ __ ] third active
guardians of galaxies like I know I
asked to go it's heartbreaking sure
enough but this look will say hey you
know what it could be the take on
Superman nobody ever knew they wanted
but they finally got can't fly though
can't fly so I'll save a bunch of money
maybe they can jump a lot
Krypton is one big bad side all right
that's one show they also picked up
Grant Morrison's happy now this sounds
[ __ ] phenomenal I have this book he
brought it over when he kid when he was
on nepo soda fat man on top man cool
idea yeah sounds like a real hard-edged
[ __ ] what was that movie that was out
when we were kids drop dead Fred who
[ __ ] up like a [ __ ] up drop dead
Fred yes like a harvey on acid oh my god
I went to drop dead Fred and you're
right it's even more classic in its
origins that's right it's very Harvey
Harvey Jimmy Stewart all over this could
you imagine that Jimmy Stewart play the
[ __ ] what is the authority cow could
be alone enix sax played by lon orders
Chris Maloney an intoxicated Crump next
cop turned hitman that play by memory
stored while we're shopping
I'm adrift in the world of casual murder
show their second betrayal 90% the
audience's whose Jimmy Stewart
what are these impressions and ask your
grandfather that's right this real funny
your granddad is in there Oh me feel
like now those bars know funny yeah what
I'm human oh all right
oh happy sounds [ __ ] good yeah so
[ __ ] in Chris Melones in it and the
voice of happy is Bobby morning from SNL
yo we got my money I don't have to pay
because on television but [ __ ] yes but I
pay for sci-fi already to my cable
package so they already have my money
already in the bag for the show next are
you are you watching the American Gods
not yet are you digging
I seen the first three episode I'm
waiting for the entire responses and
it's it's it hit over it stars right
yeah they they're spending all the
[ __ ] money on it and make a good [ __ ]
I'm making good [ __ ] like there's stuff
on that show that I've never seen on TV
before
really
they are they're going for it in almost
every conceivable way like they're
absolutely leaning into all that's an
angry leprechaun they're calling him a
leprechaun oh there's a bison with his
eyes on fire right cool there's a
there's a gay genie and a Middle Eastern
man who totally can have a bunch of sex
this episode all right cool fair enough
I Love Lucy asked you she want to see
your tits yes
Gillian Anderson who plays a Lucille
Ball really yes well she's she's media
right and she appears to the hero
Shadowmoon in like a Best Buy and she
just takes over all the screens as Lucy
trying to seduce him over to the dark
side of the force basically oh my god
yeah once you lose these kids yes that
is Gillian Anderson yeah so black and
white the hair all up [ __ ] lipstick
on polka dot dress
Wow get thee to a nunnery all right so
I'm looking for American Gods American
Gods on the Stars how many episodes they
doing for their season I think they're
doing eight so there are they all of
them Ford you can get previews I saw I
saw the first three had aired I've seen
the fourth one early cuz I know some
people that is that's a sounds a good
and not for nothing but I would watch
I would watch a McShane do almost
anything including my mom I mean if he
would do my mom I would fly him in for
that how is it mom
probably keeps cursing Tiger he was here
in this house he was here in this
[ __ ] RZA Ian McShane stood in this
very spot that we're standing right now
why poetry reading event here for that
most noble of causes private school
children meeting you needy very no one
more needy they need your money and we
had a bunch of famous people carrie
fisher's right here and for the poetry
event but ian mcshane was here then i'll
i know everyone's like deadwood but like
my favorite McShane is ian mcshane is a
Teddy black magic nerubian uh sexy beast
oh he's so damn [ __ ] scary he's
literally one of the five scariest
people I've ever seen in a movie you
know though I was like here's the bad
guy I think I'm afraid of him this dude
you were legit scared of peers that as a
[ __ ] it was on NBC a thousand years ago
called kings
yeah he was it's you know modern-day
retelling of the King David story news
late King Silas who gets dethroned by
young David or the cross Michelle but
there's this amazing scene where he
plays the dad to Sebastian Stan who lays
his son as young gay son who can't be
gay because he's in line for the throne
and just watching him just wrap his
mouth around these [ __ ] lines and
just deliver these things that that
sound like almost high Shakespearean
who's wearing a suit and it's if you've
never seen Kings you should go see Kings
especially because they in McShane be
Michael Greene who created Kings is the
co-creator of American Gods I met him at
I am Dion the way I'm reloading sandy
out a really nice guy and that dude is
having a [ __ ] year he's got some
other big rival game he co-wrote a
co-write that a lean covenant oh my god
really
Blade Runner holy [ __ ] heard around the
Orient Express holy [ __ ] and American
Gods in the same [ __ ] calendar year
what do you think like he just he wrote
some of them years ago and it all I'm
sure I'll get your [ __ ] lined up I'm
like a planet in the ether cheers to
Michael Green actually rolling in that
very same color having a [ __ ] year
goddamn man and finally mark before we
get out of here we have to bid a fond
farewell a bit of Jew if you will last
week we had to bid adieu to Michael
parks great Michael parks from read save
this video right here on this very
channel of me eulogizing him on Babylon
26 minutes long collapse yankor chips
but we lost another great old actor
wasn't even as old as Michael Michael
was 77 and [ __ ] booth died and he was
under 70 he was 63 64 something like
that number not die he had D years left
on that clock what is your powers Boothe
go-to of course you could point to for
the purposes of this show Sin City Sin
City agents of shield he had agents of
shield you know like there's I think
tombstone is my way back wonderful - so
what about Red Dawn [ __ ] yeah deed cut
that's right and even before that was
there was southern comfort which was the
kind of deliverance like not knockoff
but right but he was just as wacky
movie he was just this perfect sinewy
baguette it was something super muscular
about him even when he was playing
compromised so [ __ ] intoxicating just
to watch that dude on screen he had a
presence a real swagger to him what was
the row and Nixon in Oliver Stone's
Nixon he opens the movie goes in the
Nixon talking about how he has to retire
to get he'll Hager and he's [ __ ] great
on Deadwood because Deadwood had maybe
the best cast ever assembled in the
history of television an amazing
performer wonderful actor and gone way
too soon man good anybody I didn't read
every obit on him was powers Boothe his
real name good question because if so
well done mama boy yet somebody was just
like you're bound for greatness week
hours please [ __ ] max Paula how was
booth
his mom was right he was bound for
greatness he was indeed we salute you
powers Boothe pulling one after the
movie um there it is folks Batman I'm
Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm uh come back
next episode same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]